now Vladimir zaranski says investigators
in the city of Hassan who have uncovered
evidence of hundreds of war crimes
committed by Russian occupiers Ukrainian
president was speaking after the City
and surrounding region were liberated on
Friday Russian forces destroyed much of
the physical infrastructure before
pulling out but for residents the main
thing is their God
days on from her son's Liberation
residents of all ages still haven't
stopped celebrating
after eight months of Russian occupation
they're Overjoyed to see the Ukrainian
flag and Ukrainian soldiers finally back
we have no electricity no water no
internet no Communications no healing
but there are no Russians either and
that's why we're happy the rest will be
restored everything will be fine we are
happy Ukraine is back which is the most
important thing
with much of the city's infrastructure
destroyed volunteers have already begun
Distributing much needed Aid to
Residents facing shortages of food
medicine and water but president
zelensky has warned that the Russian
occupation left far worse than just
deprivation in its wake
thank you
investigators have already documented
more than 400 Russian war crimes bodies
of both civilians and Military are being
found in the Carson region the Russian
army left the same savagery behind as in
other regions of our country that it
managed to invade
while Russian forces have pulled back
over the now destroyed antonitsky Bridge
which linked Hassan City to the
russian-controlled Eastern Bank of the
nipro river the city and its surrounding
region remain well in range of moscow's
artillery
but despite the danger and the
deprivation in her son the celebrations
go on
Dr Marina Myron is from the defense
studies department at King's College
London she joins us from the German city
of Munich welcome to DW doctor can we
start with next steps with Ukrainian
troops now back in control of her son do
they still have to worry about the city
coming under attack
of course her son remains a city to be
worried about because the Russian forces
have placed themselves on the Eastern
Bank of the river so they will be
shelling her Zone it is to be expected
however it will not be the main focus
for Russia
um the reason behind the pull out they
had a lot of elite troops trooped in her
son on the right Riverbank and they
needed to relocate them so we are to
expect to ship shift of focus in the
military operation from the Russian side
now they're moving their Elite forces to
the netsk and are most likely to go and
try to reinforce their positions along
with the Tuple however we have to
remember that their forces are on the
Eastern Riverbank and they need less
forces to be able to hold their
defensive positions there right so just
just looking I'm how do you see the the
Moscow playing this now because we've
seen a sort of shift of a focus when the
war started they were talking about uh
taking the capital and then it was all
about securing the East and now we've
seen them moved out of here song
how are they now selling what they're
trying to achieve
well basically we have
War was wasn't on a flawed assessment of
how Ukraine and the Western countries
would react so we have two Dimensions
here we have the political Dimension
obviously the political leadership is
expecting something of the military to
achieve that military is not able to
achieve and we see it on the battlefield
therefore they have to recalibrate and
adjust their military strategic approach
and the change is coming when General
surveillance was appointed to overseas a
military operation in Ukraine because
there was no single theater commander
who was aware of what was going on and
the other issue is that there is not
enough manpower from the Russian side
and the war has been dragging on much
longer than Russia had expected so now
they have to look at how they utilize
the force that they have in Ukraine so
from from the military perspective it
actually it's the first time that it
makes sense that the Russians have
retreated frankerson rather than trying
to hold on to it and lose a lot of
Manpower and make it into a bloody fight
from a political perspective Putin has
not voiced his opinion but I assume he's
awaiting what is going to happen at the
G20 Summit which he will not be
attending to see
um how to design the military operation
according to the outcomes of the meeting
okay and once more we see the emerging
evidence of war crimes committed
following a Russian occupation and given
what we've seen in places like Buca and
kharkiv and Sumi this looks less like
ill-discipline and more like standard
operating procedure can we speculate on
what's likely to be behind this method
of operation
okay
the problem is that
um investigating what has happened in
Curson right now is too early sometimes
it takes years to uncover war crimes and
an example being the war crimes
committed by the Australian special
forces in Afghanistan which took years
to uncover however we see war crimes
being committed in Ukraine obviously in
a lot of places so we can't safely
assume that Russia doesn't operate
according to the same legal Norms that
Western forces operate and still we see
this in Wars happen it happens
um
both in Russia with Russian forces are
operating it happens also in places like
Iraq by the U.S forces so right now this
is in the media space to show how bad
Russians are however we have to be
careful to make any judgments right now
certainly every war has war crimes being
committed there are no perfect Wars and
no perfect forces so right now it is
really too early to tell whether is this
is being Amplified by the informational
medium however we will need to wait and
see what actually happened and that will
require an independent International
commission to investigate and that will
take years and just a couple of days
thank you so much for that Dr Marina
amaran from King's College London
thank you